as we know all too well it is the Assad
regime that are primarily responsible
for this policy of sustained systematic
starvation by the population of Syria we
go with people queuing to access food
banks emergency does the Prime Minister
think it's a priority for the country to
bring back foxhunting i feel the UK
hasn't gave this crisis the diplomatic
priority it demanded more reassurance
can you give me the link can you give
the house that that a tactical focus on
airstrikes won't distract or undermine
those vital attempts to achieve a
ceasefire and a political transition the
previous government carried out a
detailed assessment of what the opinion
has delivered for the people of the
United Kingdom known as a balance of
competences reviewed and yet all has
gone quiet and I wondered whether the
right animal gentlemen would let me know
when his government will come forward
with an overview of all 32 reports to
show the British people what the
European Union has delivered and help
inform the debate